well let's talk about a super common one
that's horrible cigarettes you you got
cooked by that bug re got hooked by that
bug red band still hooked Joey Diaz
kicked it you know that's a that's a
really really really common one man that
sort of defines people on that guy who
smokes I'm gonna walk in this store and
even though I know these things cause
cancer I'm gonna buy up in here I'm
gonna go outside and I can't wait to
light it up I'm just not even thinking
about that right now man I'm trying to
relax you get that thinking about eh get
there you go and you you take that drag
and you feel that cancer-causing
chemical rush yep and you're like I'll
take it I'm alright today no cancer
today when you take a big deep breath
you blow it out you look at the other
fellow cancer Dodgers and they're just
looking at you and in smoking together
and everybody just they're just really
good at dodging cancer so you know
another one way you could actually say
it is like every time you do that you're
planting a seed so every time you smoke
a cigarette you could imagine that you
have this field right and the field is
your health and in that field anytime
you like exercise or do something you
know decide instead of eating the
[ __ ] ice cream you're gonna eat the
seaweed chips or like any time you do
that you could just imagine obviously
it's not the way it works exactly but
you could think I'm planting a seed in
this field right so if I keep planting
certain types of seeds in any type of
field and I cultivate those seeds
they're gonna grow into something yeah
right that's Karma so what when when you
know for a person when the cancer comes
when the muscles come when the failure
comes when the success comes if you look
at that moment you realize this is
actually the flowering of a thing that's
been growing for a very long time inside
of me or in the world or in time so
that's the idea people already have
within them planted all of these seeds
that haven't haven't been expressed yet
into time because they're still inside
of them like the dude with the like
imagine a guy with the guy who like shot
the guy because he had road rage you
know mmm that guy for years had a really
bad anger
sorter and he knew it you know there he
would look he would think at times in
this very comest moments I sure get
really angry all the time I don't know
if this is normal all right a lot of
those people were beaten when they were
kids that's it dude yeah super common
yeah yeah for common trauma mm-hmm so
yeah man that's like cigarette smoking
any kind of behavior that like is risky
or overtime produces some kind of
negative result
it's just planting seeds you know you
know and so the momentum you're
experiencing right now is the sum total
of all those [ __ ] seeds that you
plant it and that we're planted inside
of you over the course of your life
that's what you're you are you're like a
walking field of karma at varying stages
of growth growing varying types of
vegetations
and some are good and some are bad but
it's like that's what you are right now
and what's beautiful about that is that
means that you can start cultivating
that field you know you don't have to
just like let it grow wild and pretend
every time you smoke a cigarette or do
some stupid [ __ ] you're like an
unconscious farmer you know right oh my
god what believe I'm drinking and
driving again but gotta get home there
you ocean oh my god the DUI plant grew
again in the field I wonder why that
thing keeps growing in my field
well could you keep [ __ ] drinking and
driving
dude the DUI plan yeah yeah yeah yeah
you can cultivate it that's what's
beautiful yeah you know you can
cultivate the field you don't have to
let it just like have [ __ ] weird
random wheat spring up though what a
patch or to have some weeds cuz those
are fun and I just spending that tobacco
money and spending that money thinking
about all that cancer just spending all
that money guard just buying a big
castle or all that can't some money
castle cancer hey the people want it
they want it yeah in this country you've
got the freedom to buy whatever you want
well yeah right I mean it's a person's
choice but but to get back to what you
were just saying the ethics of the
[ __ ] thing how about this how many
people who run Big Tobacco own stock in
companies that make chemotherapy drugs
there's a big question like how many of
those people in their portfolio that
they barely know about that they're like
well you know like really big investment
these days is a gene therapy for cancer
really is cancer out of hand these days
huh really interesting I wonder what
could be going wrong
the problem with cigarettes is that
they're addictive well just if they kill
you yeah they're addictive like I've
smoked a cigarette before and it gives
you a head rush more like a nice little
weird rush it's a and also the other
problem is nicotine is a medicine and it
has like some health benefits if used in
the right way and also it's a nootropic
so yeah it's like not it's not just like
it gives you a rush it's like it's it's
sometimes you're broke a little bit even
King said that was one of the most
difficult things when he quit smoking
right was not having one-way rights
that's right yeah yeah yeah cuz you
because that's the nature of addiction
it's like kudzu does to trees it wraps
around your favorite thing in life and
tricks you into kudzu kudzu is a plant
that was introduced from Japan and I
think from Japan into the south and it's
just a growing wheat vine that when it
wraps around trees and it covers them up
completely so the trees can't get any
Sun and the trees just die yeah it
wasn't native to the United States so
sometimes I don't know maybe they took
care of kudzu but when I was a kid you
would drive by these beautiful forests
that were where the trees were just
covered in [ __ ] cuts it yeah like
holy [ __ ] yeah that's crazy it's like
they got eaten yeah other plants that's
right man and those trees are dying they
can't get the Sun that oh my god yeah
it's insane yeah and that's a great
metaphor for addiction but your
reference yeah it is a perfect metaphor
yeah oh my god that's insane how did I
not know about this I don't know it's
definitely seems like something you know
about look it looks like they're alive
looks like people do there's just too
much
- no there's too much cool